major drug companies are paying billions
to settle opioid lawsuits and nevada
will get more than 280 million dollars
which our attorney general calls a major
victory but what will be done with all
that money and will it have any effect
on drug overdoses the eight news now
i-team's george knapp has a story
we're very proud of that because where
we've begun getting money into our state
very early to help address
this opioid crisis in january nevada
attorney general aaron ford took a
victory lap of sorts when he announced
the latest settlement with big pharma
companies related to opioid lawsuits
nevada will score 285 million dollars
paid over 18 years to go along with a
previous settlement of 50 million that
could be paid to the state this year
some of the money will trickle down to
local governments but what will the
state do with its cut are you able to
sort of ear market for say anti-drug
programs or specifically to help addicts
or is that up to the legislature well
it's the latter advisory committees can
make recommendations to the legislature
ford says but ultimately lawmakers will
make that call this is being driven by
litigation that the people involved in
this
aren't talking about millions of dollars
they're talking about billions and
billions of dollars
dan laird is both a pain management
doctor and an attorney he's filed
lawsuits on behalf of chronic pain
patients who've been denied medications
in the aftermath of the great opioid
crackdown far more common are lawsuits
filed by state and local governments
against big pharma
more than 1500 of them at last count
laird says governments see the drug
companies as big atms that will spit out
cash even though the current opioid
crisis has little to do with legal
prescriptions the explosion of pill
mills and over-prescribing that began in
the late 90s are pretty much gone
nationally opioid prescriptions have
declined every year since 2011 yet
overdose deaths have gone up ever since
including a 55 percent spike in nevada
in 2020 but the culprits are illicit
street drugs notably fentanyl and heroin
both of which are cheap plentiful and
smuggled into the us by drug cartels
this massive study conducted for
veterans hospitals found that 73 percent
of current ods are caused by illicit
opioids in some states it's as high as
87 percent huge upswing in opioid deaths
has occurred because of fentanyl yet
they continue to to pound this drum that
it's prescription opioids causing the
deaths aaron ford says his office is
aware of the distinction from 2019 or
2020 for example opioid-related
overdoses of overdose deaths increased
by 76
and opioid-related emergency department
encounters increased by 26 percent and
the use of fentanyl increased by 227
percent and so again we talk about
opioids but we also try to uh highlight
uh these certain aspects of opioid abuse
and thousands of people have died
because of their greed but the ag's
office has repeatedly blurred the line
between prescription opioids illicit
opioids and drug deaths in general the
three categories are used
interchangeably the ag's website decries
the terrible scourge of the opioid
epidemic but then defines opioids as
addictive drugs prescribed for pain
which certainly is not an accurate
portrayal of the main killer illicit
fentanyl the january news release
touting the big pharma settlement blames
drug companies for creating quote the
ecosystem of addiction and for the
deaths the i-team previously examined
every opioid related death as reported
by the clark county coroner for a
two-year period and found that nearly
all of them involved multiple illicit
substances as well as deadly diseases
even gunshot wounds but anyone with the
trace of opioids is considered an opioid
death red lawhern a long time advocate
for americans with chronic pain thinks
big dollar opioid settlements add fuel
to the fire millions of legitimate
patients have had their prescriptions
cut or eliminated because addicts are
dying from street drugs doctors have
stopped prescribing pain relievers or
have left the field altogether seniors
who get the most
opioid prescribing
have the lowest rates of opioid overdose
related deaths
by a factor of three to one
kids under the age of 19
have the lowest prescription rates for
opioids
and they have a rate of
opioid related overdose death that is
three times that of seniors
aaron ford agrees that the needs of
nevadans with chronic pain must factor
into future decisions about opioid
policies in the meantime he says
additional settlements with drug
companies are in the works george knapp
8 news now